you can can I add a little bit to the or
amplify a bit um so so Tony rightly
picked up where I left off I think the
big issue is confronting us now is no
longer those hassles over Rawls public
reasons and so forth but how the
discourse should be conducted in public
and I think part of that has to be
helping religious people and
non-religious people I'm going to use a
metaphor now find a political voice now
let me explain what I mean by that in
the following way when I was teaching
here at Yale I taught the philosophy of
religion course and in almost always
there would be summoned three weeks into
the course who'd come from one of the
evangelical Christian colleges so this
would always be a grad student somewhere
in the university who would ask a
question in the class and I lot even
though was a sizable class there were
allowed questions but ask the question
in such well as a parody a little bit as
if he were at an evangelical campfire
and so I have to call the student aside
afterwards well you know I can be a
little bit more specific it'd be sort of
of the sort well as Jesus says in you
name a john three sixteen and so forth
and I'd see all the other kids in the
quest you know stiffening their backs
and and opening their eyes widened
whispering we were this where this guy
come from and soph way so I'd have to
pull the student aside afterwards and
say you've got it you can you can ask
roughly that question but you've got to
find the right voice for it then I
should remember one of them who
immediately said to me what do you mean
the right voice oh I said listen just
listen for a while don't say anything
for a while but listen for several weeks
so there
so you know what I mean there is there
is such a thing as finding the right
voice to ask the questions in an in a
classroom some ways of asking virtually
the same question would just be totally
disruptive and it's very difficult to
say what that voice is I think what we
have to someone collectively do is help
people find help religious and
non-religious people find the right
political voice Martin Luther King was a
genius said having discovered the voice
right he eat that that that's a
brilliant example of what I mean by the
voice so it's not the content but it's a
pretty subtle matter of voice can't do
better than that